in order to start asking the question
what does the key word this refer to we
really need a code example where the key
word this appears here we have it
appearing inside a function which is
generally how you're going to see it so
if you notice the key word this
appearing somewhere in a function what
would you imagine it is bound to let's
go through a quick list of things that
people frequently think it's bound to
although it usually is not so first of
all you might see this function
definition here highlighted in blue and
you know that when your interpreter hits
it it's going to create a function
object in memory you may then conclude
that the key word this should refer to
that function object but it doesn't as a
next step sometimes people conjecture
that an instance of that function is
created and the key word this refers to
it now in certain circumstances that's
true but in order to really get on board
with that definition I would have to ask
what is it that you imagine a new
instance of this function would be I
mean strictly speaking what is this
object in your mind later on we're going
to go on to examine how this could be
considered true but it's actually rarely
the case that you're going to see code
that looks like this so let's say for
the sake of argument that this is
basically an error
generally speaking you might then think
that in order for the keyword this to
mean anything it must be in a function
that is contained within some other
object as a property here we have an
object ob2 that has a method called
method that stores a reference to that
same function object so that object
creates an object in memory and maybe
that in memory object where the function
is a property would be the thing that
the keyword this refers to this is
actually one of the most popular
misconceptions but it's also not the
case and we'll see why in just a minute
the easiest way to think about this
though is what if that same function was
a property of two different objects it
doesn't stand to reason that the keyword
this would be forced to choose somehow
between the two of them taking it a step
further we could then claim that the key
word this will appear inside a function
and that function must appear inside the
curly braces of some object literal or
some other form of defining a function
so that object literal that surrounds
the function definition might create an
in memory object and that could be what
we're referring to when we say the key
word this but this is also not correct
lastly we know we'll eventually call
this function
and as we passed values in to be bound
to the positional parameters of the
function we could imagine that that
invocation creates a set of bindings or
a scope that scope must be modeled
somewhere in memory and maybe it's
represented as an object where a maps to
3 in this case and B maps to 4 we would
either call this an execution context or
a scope but this is also not what the
key word this refers to as we recall
from our earlier conversation about
scopes it's not the case that JavaScript
gives you any memory reference access to
these constructs